so i'm just like i think i can just like
grab my legs and just [ __ ] do that
[Music]
i'm tom segura and i'm going to answer
the internet and go to my website for
tickets
would you
kill baby hitler
if it had to be in a very gruesome way
yeah
i mean that's not hard well
i mean to each his own but like you know
there's a picture of an axe like you
gotta like take a [ __ ] axe to the
head of a baby i would disembowel that
baby
with an accident he's just cute adolf he
doesn't know yet you know he's gonna
yeah but you know you know what you do i
agree but you since you know what you do
is you go in there with like his one of
his speeches in your earbuds yeah and so
you're listening i was into iceland and
then you didn't out and you're like
[ __ ] you so you kill him as you're
listening to grown-up hitler yeah and
then his parents come in and they're
like what the [ __ ]
and you're like you don't know
that's what i mean though in that moment
you don't know how many jews are going
to thank me for this would you
switch your penis size with your foot
size absolutely
no doubt in my mind
they're nothing they're 10 and a half
but yeah i mean that's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
but you got to walk around but then you
got yeah like so then i got a little
dick feed which side oh i thought you
just meant would you want here oh no so
now you're walking with like probably a
size like six shoe okay
i mean it is comical people would always
be like what's up with your little baby
feet but
and then then you gotta think like the
whole point of having a dick let's say
let's say you're not married though
every time but how fun
how fun would it be for people to be
like oh you got little feet i know what
you and then you just pull out this
hammer and people were like what the
[ __ ] man
you got a 10 and a half inch dick
you rather have a good hand job from
your grandmother
or a bad hand job from your grandmother
honestly
i'd rather have a good one
really yeah just to have the memory of
like
i don't remember much from my
grandmother so
imagine like if she really made you come
hard and it's like it's that orgasm
you're always chasing
you know you start telling the girl
she's like how do you know this you're
like my grandmother
would you rather have two normal kids
or one disabled kid and one kid in the
nfl what in the [ __ ] man
you guys wrote this this is a call like
a call to our show many years ago well
that's a really tough one
only because i love football
how disabled is the kid
oh really
two normal kids
would you rather live for the rest of
your life with a sensation right before
you sneeze [ __ ] or come oh my god
you have to pick one of those
all right those are all crippling by the
way
yeah those are terrible
i mean the sneeze one
you literally have to like i pause
i life goes on pause yeah are you light
induced
yeah yeah yeah it's big time me too
people people who don't do that like
they think it's crazy
is that true i don't know if it's if i i
know that it's uh it's genetic like it's
in your dna i didn't know that yeah it's
called light induced sneezing right yeah
i like walk out of a movie theater i'm
like
i just [ __ ]
see this thing
the feeling of like you're about you
need right before you [ __ ] oof
or come i mean that that means you're
like you have like blue balls yeah i
guess that's true
i guess [ __ ]
i mean also hurt though
yeah but it's like [ __ ] is it you just
the thing is you would just end up
[ __ ] eventually and also you'd end
up [ __ ] on accident a bunch and
you'd be like oh this is a thing i
always feel yes
i guess i'll just [ __ ] everywhere
if someone asks for a picture of your
balls and you don't answer are you an
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] drunk is what you
are
[Laughter]
you're goddamn you're drunk
would you rather wake up to a [ __ ] or
a hundred dollars under your pillow
every morning probably two bridges i'm
getting a thousand
what's the number to make it not a
[ __ ]
under the pillow every morning
it's like 500 bucks enough no
a thousand no ten thousand
how rich is thompson
i guess 20 25
grand
yeah yeah
i'm on tour
i'm on tour here all right listen when
the tour is over i'll be like all right
let's [ __ ] bring that number down
tighten up a little bit but right now
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] you have a choice
between a sum of money and world peace
how much money would it take you take
for you to give up world peace
no i like suffering i uh i want things
to get a little worse
i mean there's a higher rate for kobe
you know oh yeah yeah
i mean just chaos people
not being able to
you know get health care it's great
yeah there's there's no amount of money
if you had there's a lot of blow job
stuff if you had the flexibility to blow
yourself would you do it
that's more of a philosophical question
well yeah first of all would i do it of
course anybody who says no to that
i'm saying i might do it once there's no
way i have the ability i'm like never
gonna give it a shot yeah you're gonna
try and be like all right this is weird
um
but if it's awesome then i'm doing it
all the time all the time right and like
what if everybody knew i'd be like yeah
can you blow yourself would you would
you think if if it was public you would
just be able to you would just own it be
like yeah definitely how about you lame
asses who can't suck your own i mean you
know once you're like you're in your 40s
and you're like oh yeah you're just like
more comfortable with yourself you're
like i feel like if you're in your 40s
you blow yourself and it's good
you turn back to like when you're like
13 and jerking off everywhere like you'd
be like where's tom like he's up in his
room and i'd be like i would be showing
people how i do it like how would you do
it how do you go about it
i mean a lot of spit and
more like physically like oh would you
like well i tried you know when i was a
kid and i just kind of like only that
just trying to like
he went on his back and through his legs
over his head yeah
well i'm imagining that i'm wildly
flexible in this scenario
so i'm just like i think i can just like
grab my legs and just [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah so you're like you're not even
brought your face [ __ ] yeah of course
yeah would you rather be the president
the pope or whoever is in charge of
north korea
well i i mean i i think it would be
[ __ ] awesome to be
the pres the the
a kim in north korea okay
well yeah
some of them get lit up by aircraft
carrier guns well yeah but if you're in
charge you're you're lighting up people
yeah yeah i mean
yeah yeah so i think what i would do is
i would take that for a ride like just
being the the guy in charge the
demagogue like
just be a kim like palace you know
[ __ ] have your aunt killed in front
of you i think you have to be able to
release the dogs on people yeah like you
flex on that for a little bit you enjoy
it and then you can also play the role
of like you know what i'm gonna take us
into the age of democracy so you become
like a hero but you still like you know
you [ __ ] your harem for a while like you
have some fun
dennis rodman yeah dude like you you
[ __ ] stone a few people to death and
then you're like all right
this was a ride i gotta go if you were
taken hostage five years ago
what would surprise you most about the
world today
i mean
five years ago what was that 20
16
you missed
you missed the last
what presidency yeah so that that would
be like what
uh
yeah you'd be like that's crazy and then
they're back then a pandemic happened
you're like wait wait when
um still still
i mean honestly it'd probably be only
fans i'd be like that's probably okay
it's
100 for free
it says for three thousand dollars would
you get your face photoshopped into a
gay porno i'm sure it exists already
and they can put my face on whatever
they want yeah
so yeah that's a freebie
they faked me under the taliban under
like
all kinds of [ __ ] i'm like what are you
gonna do fight the internet they can't
do it yeah
yeah sure
if you agree with tom that kevin is an
idiot and tries to suck his own dick the
wrong way subscribe right now for ati
leave a comment with the more comedians
you want to say to have him come in and
tell kevin he tried to suck his own dick
in the wrong fashion hit the
notification button hit the notification
button in order to remember ah tip it
to subscribe
[ __ ] subscribe
i don't want to do this again